Hola Bienvenidos a la entrevista de
Franz 24 en español en esta oportunidad
nos acompaña María Teresa hablandon ella
es activista defensora nicaragüense de
los Derechos Humanos también es
socióloga directora de la asociación
programa regional feminista la corriente
una fuerte y muy potente voz encontrar
el gobierno de Daniel Ortega y las
persecuciones y abusos a los Derechos
Humanos que sufren muchísimas personas
en Nicaragua María Teresa Blandón
Muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
24 en español Gracias a ustedes por la
oportunidad de hablar sobre la situación
de Nicaragua absolutamente
necesario hablar de este tema María
Teresa ongs medios de comunicación
cerrados activistas Defensores de
Derechos Humanos encarcelados
perseguidos incluso condenados al exilio
también Hablamos de ataques a la iglesia
católica entre muchas otras violencias y
abusos a los Derechos Humanos como
el momento político y social que vive en
Nicaragua y el origen y el objetivo de
todas estas represiones y violencias
bueno en principio yo diría que es una
situación
terriblemente dolorosa para la sociedad
nicaragüense Pero también es una
situación
insostenible en el tiempo porque ningún
país puede
sostenerse sobre la base de la violencia
de la intolerancia de la represión de la
persecución a quienes piensan diferente
y a quienes demandan un cambio de rumbo
en el país
en abril del próximo año estaríamos
cumpliendo cinco años de crisis
ininterrumpida que como ya sabemos
inició con una brutal masacre perpetrada
por
los cuerpos policiales y para policiales
en contra de las protestas cívicas que
llevaron a cabo por un lado
personas de la tercera edad en protesta
por reformas al sistema de pensiones y
por el otro lado estudiante
universitarios reclamando la atención
del régimen
a a la crisis socioambiental que vive
nuestro país
a partir de ahí pues se han conculcado
absolutamente todos los derechos civiles
y políticos a la ciudadanía nicaragüense
ahora María Teresa Cómo sufren las
mujeres y el movimiento feminista en
particular esta persecución hay una
violencia diferencial hacia ustedes
tendría que decir que las mujeres hemos
sufrido desde que el régimen de Daniel
Ortega y Rosario Murillo regresó al
gobierno en el año 2007 porque han
llevado a cabo una agenda
conservadora y se han negado
sistemáticamente a reconocer derecho a
las mujeres sobre todo aquellos que
tienen que ver con la autonomía sobre
sus cuerpos y el derecho a vivir libre
de violencia durante esto últimos
dieciséis años se han desmontado los
pocos avances que habíamos alcanzado en
materia de prevención de la violencia y
en materia de
salud sexual y reproductiva para citar
dos ejemplo importantes pero también
durante todo tiempo ha incrementado la
pobreza en general y la pobreza de las
mujeres en particular de tal manera que
la inmensa mayoría de la fuerza de
trabajo femenina está en el desempleo o
en el empleo precario ganando muy bajo
salarios las mujeres indígenas en
condiciones de extrema pobreza las
mujeres Rurales sin acceso a la tierra
las trabajadoras de la maquila
sufriendo una sistemática violación a
sus derechos laborales esto lo venimos
denunciando frente a una falsa retórica
de equidad de género que ha manejado el
régimen Ortega Murillo y más
recientemente pues la hostilidad del
régimen en contra de la Organización
de mujeres y organizaciones feministas
se ha expresado en el cierre de más de
organizaciones y en la mayoría de los
casos la confiscación de sus bienes
estamos hablando de ongs además no ahora
María Teresa tanto usted como muchísimas
compañeras activistas denunciaron la
persecución y también algo muy terrible
que es el exilio el exilio no el
destierro algo que se denomina represión
migratoria No usted misma sufre esa
situación y el destierro como decíamos
es una de las formas de violencia más
crueles que pueden existir cuéntenos
Cómo cambió su vida sus vínculos su
activismo todo hasta donde pueda y desee
por supuesto
Bueno quiero decir que yo soy una de de
los tantos nicaragüenses que hemos sido
Víctimas de ese tipo de de represión
algunas personas han sido impedidas de
salir de Nicaragua a otra se le ha
retenido el pasaporte para que no puedan
salir a otra se le han negado la
renovación de su pasaporte y a otras
como es mi caso
no impidieron regresar al país en esa
condición estamos al menos dieciséis
mujeres defensoras de derecho humano y
ciertamente es una situación difícil
porque te obliga a hacer cambio
drásticos en tu vida pero también
a suspender vínculos familiares vínculo
afectivo vínculos orgánicos también con
tus colectivos de trabajo
Y porque también eso te obliga a
invertir mucha energía para tratar de
reacomodar tu vida digamos en
situaciones Generalmente
desventajosas no entonces el tema es que
entendemos claramente que esto es una
forma de o una estrategia para tratar de
de silenciarnos para impedir que que la
sociedad nicaragüense se continúe
organizando y continúe denunciando la
violación de derechos humanos y
exigiendo un cambio de régimen en
nuestro país ahora se da una suerte de
interacción muy interesante no porque
bueno como decíamos la Iglesia Católica
es un blanco importantísimo no de
permanentes ataques de persecución por
parte del gobierno y si bien las
feministas han tenido históricamente
diferencias ideológicas muy marcadas con
esta institución ahora sin embargo se
encuentran mismo lado sufriendo la misma
opresión verdad
estamos Del mismo lado y lo y lo tuvimos
claro desde abril del 2018
cuando la Iglesia Católica
O al menos la mayoría de los jerarcas de
la Iglesia Católica pues se puso de lado
del pueblo nicaragüense denunció la
barbaridades cometidas por el régimen la
la Sangrienta
represión que dejó más de 350 personas
asesinadas en aquel momento más de 800
presos y presas políticas ahora más de
220 y y bueno y miles de nicaragüenses
en el exilio
efectivamente la feministas nos hemos
pronunciado enfáticamente en Solidaridad
con la jerarquía católica
a partir de que el régimen enfocó su
digamos sus fuerzas represoras en contra
de sacerdotes que ahora mismo o están
presos o están en el exilio
la feminista sabemos diferenciar
claramente
Cuáles son nuestros Aliado del lado de
quién estamos y estamos del lado de la
justicia y estamos del lado de la
defensa de los derechos humanos y en eso
estamos juntos distintos sectores de la
sociedad Incluyendo a la iglesia
católica de tal manera que sabemos que
es absolutamente arbitrario e injusto
el encarcelamiento y la represión
ejercida contra esto sacerdote y junto a
otros sectores de la sociedad estamos
exigiendo la liberación de los que están
presos y el retorno de los que se han
visto obligados al exilio pero también
estamos denunciando la persecución que
tiene en contra de todos los católicos
al punto de prohibirles la realización
de digamos de sus celebraciones
tradicionales esto es contrario a lo que
dice la Constitución nosotras la
feministas defendemos el estado laico
uno de cuyos principios evidentemente es
el respeto a la libertad de conciencia
María Teresa bueno Nicaragua no lograron
callarla tampoco lograron hacerlo desde
el exilio como bien estamos viendo en
esta entrevista es clave verdad que la
comunidad internacional no deje solo a
los nicaragüenses Qué mensaje tiene para
darle al mundo
bueno es clave que continúen acompañando
al pueblo nicaragüense en su justa
demanda por
terminar con esta situación
terrible para para todo el pueblo
es necesario que la comunidad
internacional
se haga eco de nuestros reclamos de
nuestras demandas
urgente lograr la liberación de los más
de
230 presos y presas políticas que están
en condiciones digamos de de tortura y
de y de tratos crueles e inhumanos
Nicaragua es un país valiente es un país
con una historia extraordinaria en la
lucha contra la dictadura Nicaragua
igual que todos los pueblos de América
Latina y del Caribe merece vivir en paz
ojalá que así sea María Teresa Blandón
Se nos acabó el tiempo muchísimas
Gracias por esta entrevista en Franz 24
ha sido un placer dialogar con ustedes
realmente gracias a usted Buenas tardes
una vez más gracias a usted Y como
siempre nuestra audiencia la invitamos a
que sigan informando ser el resto de
nuestra programación y también por
supuesto en 24 punto com sigan junto a
nosotros
[Música]